soir à tous je suis vraiment très très
très content d'être avec vous alors on
va se dire aujourd'hui
bon la lumière est là mais imaginez-vous
quelques minutes une journée sans
lumière une journée totalement sans
lumière en fait
imaginez-vous ce qui pourrait se
produire tous vos sens serait en a l'air
tout le monde aurait quelque chose qui
se développerait petit à petit petit à
petit est un génie qu'on appelle le
génie de l'innovation viendrait pousser
une forme d'adrénaline qui vous
amènerait à réfléchir alors imaginez
vous cette journée sans lumière et
toutes les conséquences que cela
pourrait avoir sur votre quotidien
à présent faisons là même la même
évocation mai une journée sans gravité
et repositionnons nous de la même façon
sur cette idée que tous nos sens devrait
retrouver l'entièreté des repères notre
façon de bouger nous asseoir de marché
beaucoup de choses changeraient et bien
cela fait cent millions d'années
d'innovation que l'homme s'est
progressivement adapté à son univers il
s'est redressé
puis il s'est penché à nos son
ordinateur et se génien de l'innovation
la pousser constamment aller de l'avant
à explorer à trouver des solutions pour
maîtriser son environnement
et bien voici 17,13 1,7 milliard
d'années d'inconnus d'histoire de notre
univers cet univers que l'on découvre
petit à petit grâce à nos satellites on
compte les galaxies on pénètre les
galaxies on découvre à l'intérieur des
galaxies d'autres galaxies et on va de
plus en plus de plus en plus loin c'est
une véritable histoire qui nous fait
tourner la tête
on découvre tous les jours
des choses assez exceptionnel il ya
quelques mois deux étoiles se sont
rencontrés nous on nous ont envoyé une
onde électromagnétique et c'est ondes
électromagnétiques étaient bien reçus
bien bien évaluer et elle était mise en
corrélation avec des théories générales
comme celle de la théorie générale de
einstein se la relativité donc tous les
jours tous les jours nos satellites nous
amène un petit bout de la connaissance
dans ce monde de gravité ou d'absence ou
de microgravité que nous semblons
complètement ignoré depuis que nous
sommes sur terre
en réalité dans l'espace ça va faire dix
sept ans depuis 2000 que nous sommes en
présence permanente de l'orbité basse
nous avons des astronautes à bord de la
station spatiale qui habite la station
spatiale de manière permanente depuis 17
ans
depuis 17 ans on observe le comportement
des hommes et des femmes sur des
périodes assez prolongée plus d'un an
pour certains quelques jours pour
d'autres et on observe la réaction de
leurs corps leurs muscles leur vision
leur sens leur toucher l'or leur
perception de leur environnement c'est
le fond dans le fondement de toutes ses
activités qui ont amené à plusieurs
plusieurs années de recherches et de
résultats pendant ce temps là nos
astronautes évolué dans la station
spatiale visite 16 coucher de soleil 16
lever du soleil se lever de soleil tous
les jours
90 minutes pour faire le tour de la
terre et dans cette dans cet univers un
peu particulier il effectue des
expériences alors pas seulement
uniquement sur le corps humain sur leur
propre manière d'appréhender la
microgravité olap sous l'imposante
heures ou là la faible gravité mais nous
faisons aussi grâce à eux
un certain nombre de découvertes par
rapport à la formation matériaux la
cristallisation de matériaux nous
observons également des phénomènes
naturels des phénomènes tout à fait
physique de combustion par exemple dans
ces conditions de de gravité réduite ces
années d'expérience ont été très riches
même si finalement nous sommes dans un
milieu extrêmement extrêmement complexe
nous évoluerons dans une station
spatiale qui a à peu près la taille d'un
terrain de football qui est à 450 km
d'altitude et qui file à 28 milles
kilomètres à l'heure un endroit où nos
astronautes depuis 17 ans risquent leur
vie pratiquement tous les jours une
panne dans la ventilation créé par
exemple une bulle une bulle dans
laquelle tout ce qu'ils expirent tout le
monoxyde de carbone qui expire les
amèneraient probablement à mourir donc
une ventilation est une technologie qui
leur donneront la possibilité de
survivre mais il ya bien plus que ça il
ya le bombardement des radiations sur
les boucliers des différentes au module
il y a
les différences de température
extérieure intérieure
même si à l'intérieur les astronautes
sont dans une atmosphère totalement
similaire à celle que nous trouverons
sur la terre dans notre maison bien au
chaud 21° une atmosphère à l'extérieur
les conditions sont totalement
différentes et ils sont livrés à eux
mêmes donc ce soit des conditions
hostiles et je vous rappelle ce qu'on a
dit tout à l'heure
imaginez vous un jour sans gravité tous
les sens se met en route et c'est ça qui
pousse l'exploration s'est pas
spécialement ce qu'on est allé chercher
c'est d'être dans ces conditions pour
trouver des choses que l'on s'était pas
du tout attendu et c'est là la chose qui
démontre quelque part cette exploration
spatiale qui n'est que dans ses
premières années dans sa première
naissance
malheureusement nous sommes très
impatients nous avons envie de voir ses
résultats sur terre comme en orbite on a
besoin de comprendre on a besoin de
justifier mais pourquoi toujours vouloir
justifier évidemment c'est beaucoup
d'argent vous allez me dire mais
finalement de comprendre notre univers
de comprendre l'origine même de notre
terre permet peut-être aussi de
comprendre aussi sa destinée et donc
tout au long du chemin nous continuerons
nous continuer à à développer des
technologies qui vont nous permettre de
plus en plus à rester de manière
permanente dans cet environnement de
notre système solaire et nous allons pas
nous arrêter à 450 km nous allons
essayer d'aller plus loin et en passant
certaines choses que nous développons
servent à développer des choses
totalement imprévisible sur terre nous
avons l'exemple de cet intérêt étage
d'un système de d'absorption des chocs
entre deux étages qui est émis rudement
à l'épreuve pour développer un certain
nombre d'appareils et de prothèses comme
celle que vous voyez pour les champions
de course et de sauts ce qui ont été
amputés ont utilisé cela et ont utilisé
donc une technologie dérivée
immédiatement d'une technologie spatiale
le but n'était pas de faire ça le but
était de partir dans l'espace
c'est un tout petit exemple mais de nous
en avons plusieurs et il y en a d'autres
alors revenons sur le fil de filet par
exemple que vous avez peut-être croisé
en 2014 15 années de préparation 10
années de voyage alors tout ça ça paraît
très très long mais effectivement quelle
entreprise et tout ça pour quoi
pour rencontrer une comète pour partir
de la terre et à terrière sur une comète
ce voyage formidable nous allons écouter
pratiquement civilistes presque 7
milliards de km2 de trajet à 110 mille
kilomètres à l'heure et tout ça pour
quoi
un milliard de trajectoire mais c'est un
calcul phénoménale et c'est notre centre
a en allemagne qui nous a fait tous ces
calculs pour atterrir de manière précise
autour de ce gros caillou de 5 km de
diamètre
nous sommes là à plusieurs milliards de
km de la terre un rendez vous absolument
pas comme les autres mais qui est aussi
un rendez vous vers notre origine sur
une terre primitive celles qui auraient
été probablement une des sources de
notre vie puisque c'est par les comètes
que nous avons un apport on a on a eu
l'apport de l'eau et donc nous nous
sommes posés sur phil hay prouesse
technique hors du commun
quelque chose phénoménal quelque chose
qui a amené l'ensemble des équipes à une
aventure humaine qui n'avait pas son
pareil dans notre dans notre milieu
nous l'avons vécu en direct et je pense
que dans les dérivés des résultats de
l'espace d'avoir créé au travers de
toutes deux équipes en europe dans tous
les pays les 22 pays membres de l'agencé
spatiale européenne une telle une telle
coopération une telle solidarité autour
d'une mission comme celle là et bien
c'est un exemple qui nous a beaucoup
aidés pour l'avenir alors pourquoi pas
nous pourquoi faire tout ça à quoi ça
sert tout simplement pour nous nous
sommes là ce petit point que vous allez
sur l'écran c'est blue dot commande de
dire on fait une photo qui étaient
prises par un satellite qui s'appelle
casini qui était doté d'un autre petit
satellite qui s'appelle the games ils
étaient ensemble guen sait a atterri sur
titan et cassini a continué sa course et
il ya quelques années a pris cette photo
pratiquement de la périphérie de saturne
et nous a projeté ce petit point qui en
fait notre terre vue de là bas tout ça
pour dire que finalement nous sommes
aussi sur un vaisseau qui est un
vaisseau qui file à toute vitesse dans
un univers absolument incroyable en
pleine expansion permanente et qui nous
donne cette envie de connaître encore
plus d'aller dans le trou noir d'essayer
de comprendre quelle est cette matière
noire qu'elle est cette énergie noire
qui est derrière nous qui
qui se noue revenons vers le
commencement
repassons notre notre système solaire
revenons en arrière sur notre galaxie la
voie lactée revenons en arrière sur le
premier jour 2013 vous avez eu la
première photo celle du satellite planck
qui vous a donné une superbe
cartographie des premières nano seconde
qui faisait suite au big bang
cette photo vous l'aviez pratiquement au
début d'écran sur l'origine de ce
graphique et depuis vous avez des 13,7
milliards d'années de déploiement toute
cette connaissance
nous avons progressivement tenter
d'accumuler des indices des pistes je
vous ai parlé de casino games en 2007
avec l'atterrissage petit à petit une
connaissance de ce petit satellite de
saturne qui a l'apparence de notre terre
ça a été un point focal de nos
scientifiques pendant pendant plusieurs
dizaines d'années se poser avec un petit
un petit objet automatique dans la
périphérie t temps donc on ira plus loin
on ira sur jupiter on essaiera de faire
la même chose la même question se pose
que sur saturne sur titan est ce que
nous allons toucher un sol dur
un seul mot un seul liquide nous le
savions pas bon finalement c'est comme
si notre satellite était tombé dans un
sac de boue ou quelque chose c'était
vraiment houmous était c'était
surprenant en tout cas c'était palpitant
que sera-t-il de nos atterrissage sur
les autres planètes comment allons-nous
vivre cette expérience je vous ai parlé
de la solidarité entre les états membres
nous avons déployé un système qui
s'appelle ariane avec sa série darjanin
jusqu à rien si ce qui viendra en 2020
c'est une longue histoire une histoire
de fiabilité une histoire de constance
une histoire de connaissances de
compétences qui nous amène petit pas par
petit pas vers une grande fiabilité
celle de nos lanceurs aujourd'hui qui
nous permet de contempler les missions
spatiales dans les dizaines et dizaines
d'années qui vont venir nous avons bâti
en europe une connaissance
solide dont nous n'avons absolument pas
besoin de justifier l'importance
la seule justification qui tiennent
évidemment c'est celle qui se disent
mais est ce que toutes ces applications
qui sont données est rendue possible par
nos satellites est ce qu'on peut les
percevoir
et c'est là la grande frustration de
ceux qui travaillent que moi dans les
activités spatiales
on a difficile à faire comprendre que
dans certains iphone l'iphone weeds je
pense vous avez galileo galileo qui est
notre système de positionnement par
satellite le fameux gps à l'américaine
eh bien nous l'avons dans nos iphone et
il est européen sic une des tentatives
de démontrer que l'europe a besoin
d'être indépendante le besoin l'europe a
besoin d'avoir ces systèmes l'europe a
besoin de pouvoir contrôler ses avions
la distance entre ses avions ses
atterrissages à un mètre près même voire
mieux que cela
tout le système aérien européen sera
basé sur galileo
évidemment c'est très difficile quand
vous êtes dans l'avion vous ne percevez
pas à cela
mais galileo c'est une longue histoire
de près une histoire de longue haleine d
investissement certes mais aussi des des
prouesses technologiques comme les
horloges qui sont à l'intérieur
mais y'a pas que galilée ou dans les
applications vous avez l'ensemble des
sentinelles qui nous permette
concrètement tous les jours d'observer
les risques que nous courons en matière
de changements climatiques
c'est une série de connaissances qui de
façon continue nous permet d'accumuler
les données pour avoir la certitude que
tel et tel type d'événements seront plus
que probable mais arriveront d'une
manière inéluctable
nous allons plus loin sans regarder
nécessairement les les impacts du
changement climatique dû à l'activité
humaine nous avons les les dangers qui
proviennent également de façon naturelle
et ce sont des dangers qui sont pas
spécialement venant de la terre
elle-même elles viennent de l'extérieur
le premier c
celui qui nous vient du soleil où nous
sommes bombardés de manière constante
mais cette image nous montre là la
perfection de notre terre cette espèce
de perfection dans sa situation dans sa
localisation dans le système solaire qui
nous dit à ce moment là dans cette
région là d'un système le solaire à
cette distance là d'un soleil ces terres
là a permis la création de la vie et a
permis aussi un bouclier naturel par son
atmosphère et sont son champ électro
magnétique terrestre pour se protéger
des radiations solaires
et quand vous songez à cela et quand on
parle des exoplanètes qui sont lésés
planète qui ressemble énormément à la
terre en tout cas qui qui qui
correspondent aux critères de sélection
par rapport à la taille par rapport à
l'existant de l'atmosphère quand on
compte le nombre d'exoplanètes qu'on
nous avons découvert durant ces
dernières années nous sommes à plusieurs
milliers de petites terres en dehors de
notre système solaire
et vous imaginez aussi que pour avoir
les conditions de viabilité
il faut que toutes ces petites aires qui
ressemble à la nôtre soit positionnée
par rapport à leur soleil de la même
façon que les notre propre terre c'est
fascinant c'est absolument hallucinant
de voir que nous ne connaissons
absolument rien de tout cela mais nous
allons aller sur vénus nous allons à
lons nous allons sur mercure pour aussi
regardée des états d'avancement de notre
terre où vénus a eu son changement
climatique
nous allons sur mercure l'année
prochaine pour comprendre aussi comment
la planète de notre système solaire qui
est la plus proche du soleil a réagi et
a surtout survécu depuis le 2 la
constitution du système solaire
bepicolombo le fera ira dans cette
périphérie mercure yens elle lira dans
les débuts
d'ici la fin d'année 2010 8 c'est demain
nous allons aussi grâce aux missions
comme rosetta comprendre quelles sont
les véritables menaces nous allons les
compter ces astéroïdes qui nous menacent
et éventuellement à l'appel de l'agencé
spatiale européenne essaie de fédérer
l'ensemble des pays autour des activités
spatiales internationales pour
développer un programme qui nous
protégerait d'une attaque d'astéroïdes
car celles ci elles sont elles sont
réelles nous avons une atmosphère qui
nous protège qui brûlent entièrement
l'ensemble des météorites qui brûlent
une partie des astéroïdes si tel était
le cas
mais rappelons nous il ya eu plusieurs
cas même gravissime la dernière fois
l'astéroïde importante est passé à 40
mille kilomètres de la terre elle avait
la capacité de détruire l'entièreté de
la france
donc ce problème est réel et ce n'est
pas simplement restant là en se disant
ok l'espace est trop cher ou bien oui on
veut était plus fort on veut les
premiers la question n'est pas là la
question ici c'est comment travailler
ensemble avec les japonais avec les
chinois avec les américains les russes
les canadiens l'ensemble des pays
européens et même certaines nations qui
sont naissante dans le domaine spatial
pour essayer de comprendre comment
profiter de toute cette connaissance que
nous avons développée grâce à rosetta
pour aller chercher ces astéroïdes
mais finalement le problème des
astéroïdes et des météorites n'est pas
très loin de celui que nous avons créé
avec l'ensemble des débris spatiaux
donc les deux programmes se tiennent
d'une part on lance des satellites pour
produire plus de services que vous
utilisez tous les jours et d'autre part
il faut trouver des moyens pour quand
ces satellites arrivés en fin de vie
les nettoyer et nous faut un aspirateur
spatiale il nous faut d'abord les
comptes et les surveiller un parent
éviter les collisions vous avez tous vu
gravity ça peut arriver ça fait mal un
satellite en pleine figure à 28 km à
l'heure en sens inverse
donc il faut faire attention et la
station phase aller constamment en train
d'éviter des et d'effectuer des
manoeuvres pour éviter des collisions
avec un certain nombre d'objets donc il
faut travailler
je vous rappelle que tout en travaillant
on développe aussi des connaissances qui
sont applicables
ici tous les jours en matière de
robotique certains robots fabuleux ont
même le doigté la dextérité
nous avons tous les jours ce que nous
appelons des retombées spatiale des
retombées économiques
malheureusement il faudrait pratiquement
deux têtes complet pour vous parler de
l'ensemble de ces de ses retombées
mais la retombée principal c'est aussi
comme je le disais au départ la capacité
de l'homme de comprendre comment il peut
appréhender cet espace de microgravité
comment s'il ya une perte de masse
osseuse avéré sur la durée comment nous
pourrions développer un certain nombre
de médicaments qui nous aiderait
justement à reconstituer cette masse
osseuse et c'est là également une des
voies que nous suivons pour essayer de
développer des des pistes vers un
certain nombre de maladies
les scientifiques au sol dans tous les
domaines pharmaceutique biologie travail
avec nos équipes pour essayer d'en tirer
un maximum de cet espace un peu
particulier qui nous enlève le voile de
la gravité rappelez vous un jour sans
lumière tout ce que ça pourrait nous
apporter ou un jour sans gravité quel
serait l'impact seriez tous en train de
voler là on n'aurait plus besoin de
sièges mais voler dans l'espace c'est
pas pareil il faut se protéger
je vous ai dit le bombardement et
terrils vous avez des espaces de des
écarts de températures qui vont de -150
degrés à plus de 150 degrés un coup vous
êtes carbonisé que vous êtes congelés
donc ça ne va pas il faut trouver des
méthodes bien sûr pour vous et pour nous
qui voyons ça tous les jours
on ne s'en rend plus compte mais c'est
une prouesse technologique
certaines de ces technologies d'ailleurs
on les utilise également tous les jours
ce soit pour protéger de pompiers est
certes un certain habib qui ont besoin
de cette capacité de refroidissement de
protection contre le feu nous avons
aussi les amis connectés
que nous commençons à développer main
dans la main avec certaines équipes qui
travaillent à bord de la station
spatiale et la suite de tout ça et bien
la suite c'est la destination c'est que
vous construisez une ligne de métro
vous commencez par la ligne numéro un et
puis on va voir la ligne numéro de la
numéro 2 c'est quoi mais la ligne numéro
deux c'est la lune elle est naturelle
c'est le prochain le crush la prochaine
étape de notre parcours
donc cette lune ready pensée génère
toute une série d'innovations toute une
série d'idées
aujourd'hui l' agence spatiale
européenne a fait appel à l'ensemble de
la communauté internationale pour créer
le village spatiale le village lunaire
ce village n'est pas un village matériel
ce village est une forme de de
coopération participative d'amener des
idées
qu'est ce que vous feriez en matière de
de fabrication en trois dimensions de
fabrication ou de d'impression en 3d
qu'est ce que vous feriez pour utiliser
la rigolade qui est sur place
la transformer et créer un habitat par
un robot toutes ces idées sont
aujourd'hui clairement sur la table
elles sont discutés nous allons
travailler avec des américains est aussi
les russes pour développer des systèmes
comme le système orion qui va nous
amener très rapidement dans la
périphérie de la lune bâtir ce qu'on
appelle un deep space gatwick est une
forme de station spatiale en orbite is
lunaire et à partir de là on va avoir
notre avant postes on a le camp de base
il faut aller vers le mont everest et on
va pas s'arrêter là
tout en allant en développant ses idées
ses idées auront d'une utilité aussi
pour les voyages bien plus lointain
évidemment la différence près que pour
aller sur mars il faudra six mois il
faudra attendre un an là bas pour
pouvoir revenir faire 6 mois donc deux
ans d'investissement et c'est là
peut-être la plus grosse difficulté pour
les voyages martien c'est de se dire
qu'on allait partir pendant 2 ans
minimum et que si quoi que ce soit
devait nous arriver
eh bien on serait bloqué là-bas c'est la
seule véritable grosse gages à la
difficulté que nous avons à essayer de
développer des vols habités vers mars il
faut comprendre cet aspect de sécurité
cet aspect fondamental on va pas envoyer
des gens avec un ticket aller simple sur
mars
il faut un ticket aller retour et on y
pense et on n'est pas le seul à y penser
bien sûr les acteurs privés dans le
monde spatial sont bien réels ils ont
trouvé ils ont des idées nous apporte ce
sang neuf
elon musk et parmi ceux qui nous
apportent cette idée de casser les
règles habituelles du du programme
spatial classique repousser les limites
avoir de l'ambition vouloir aller plus
loin explorer il nous donne un parfait
exemple avec son programme martien et ça
nous bouscule ça nous fait réfléchir
rappelez vous si on avait un jour sans
gravité on serait forcé de réfléchir on
serait forcé de s'adapter
eh bien peut-être un jour qui sait
maître yoda pourra nous le dire
ce jour où nous aurons moins de gravité
que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
ce jour c'est peut-être peut-être très
proche
en tout cas c'est ce que je souhaite en
tout cas je vous remercie énormément
pour m'avoir accueilli 6 à 3
[Applaudissements]
et